d'après le ms il faudra quatre mois
avant de pouvoir fabriquer un vaccin
grande quantité rappelons que pour
l'instant le virus ne se transmet pas
d'homme à homme mais l'hypothèse est
redouté alors quels sont les modes de
contamination explications jean daniel
flaysakier voici on voit la compagnie
air virus les oiseaux migrateurs
transporte en effet dans leurs intestins
divers souche responsable de la grippe
aviaire inoffensive pour les migrateurs
ces virus peuvent décimer les élevages
de poulets de dinde comme ce fut le cas
l'an dernier en langue la grippe aviaire
fait aussi plein lourde menace sur
l'homme
car nous ne savons pas nous défendre
contre elle alors que nous pouvons nous
défendre contre la grippe que nous
rencontrons chaque hiver le virus humain
en effet à sa surface des structures que
l'on appelle les hémagglutinine dont il
se sert pour entrer dans les cellules et
des neuraminidase qui lui servent à s'en
échapper et à les infecter d'autres
tissus pour échapper au système de
défense il va changer des petits
morceaux de ces structures c'est ce
qu'on appelle le glissement et pour le
contrer on met chaque année dans le
vaccin trois souches différentes afin de
mieux le contrôler crainte majeure des
spécialistes c'est la cassure
le virus va totalement changer une
partie de sa structure externe
c'est ce qui est arrivé en 1918 c'est la
grippe espagnole 20 à 40 millions de
morts selon les diverses estimations
cassure encore en 1957 avec la grippe
asiatique un million mort qu'un sûr
toujours en 68 69 et la grippe de hong
kong sehk assure sont en fait le
résultat d'un cocktail tragique la
rencontre d'un virus aviaire et d'un
virus humain
les deux virus se retrouvent dans les
voies respiratoires d'un cochon et vont
pouvoir ainsi échanger leurs gènes ainsi
humaniser le virus aviaire peut se
transmettre très facilement entre
humains le passage par le port n'est pas
une obligation en kong en 1997 on a
constaté que les poulets ont directement
contaminés 18 personnes et causé six
décès la conjonction d'une grippe
aviaire et d'une grippe humaine serait
une véritable tragédie car il faudrait
quatre à six mois pour obtenir un vaccin
efficace et le vaccin contre la grippe
se prépare ironie du sort sur des oeufs